good morning believe nation today's
message is think long term over to you
Casey and Noble I have a rule which I
stick by and that is always replace
short term greed with long term greed
there's a lot of other pickup coaches
out there who are lone operators so that
means that they essentially do
one-on-one consultations and sessions
and they get a fair amount of money but
it takes up a lot of their time and that
time is really really valuable because
if you don't have it you're going to
stunt the growth of your business if you
want to expand and have more time to
invest in other projects and maybe start
up new ventures you're going to have to
give some of that work to trusted people
you have to build up a team and at first
yes it does affect the profits but in
the long run because you've had the time
to expand your company to expand your
brand you'll make that tenfold and
that's what I've learnt and that's what
I teach other entrepreneurs a lot of
entrepreneurs don't think long term
enough they think the here they think
the now and it forces you to make
decisions that are narrow in focus you
need to make sure that you're spending
time on a regular basis about the bigger
picture about the five-year plan about
where you're going right I think too
many entrepreneurs is one example try to
do everything themselves you try to do
everything yourself maybe you try
bringing somebody on and it didn't work
out and that one experiences jaded you
now and you go back to say listen I I
know I can do it better than everybody
else so I'm just gonna do it myself
and that's extreme short-term thinking
and limits where you can go the impact
you can have the money that you can make
you know the power that you can exert on
the world the influence that you can
build you need to be able to build a
team and think longer-term it and I get
the crunch that you might be facing
right now I may be like that's a great
idea Evan but but how am I gonna make
money right now right I gotta pay the
bills and I've got to put food on the
table and make sure my internet doesn't
go out right because I haven't paid
Phil and I get it and I'm not saying do
everything only for the long-term
I'm not saying only focus on what's
gonna happen in five years and totally
ignore what you're doing right now but
you need to make sure that you're
spending at least some time I think
ideally everyday focus on the bigger
picture I like to start it sooner I like
to start it at the beginning of the day
I call it CEO time and what I think you
have to do is block off ninety minutes a
day during your work week for CEO time
and that's when you're focused on the
bigger picture you're not worried about
the projects you have going on right now
you're not worried about how do I get my
next time in the door you worried about
the bigger thing you're gonna do to
build your brand to build your influence
to have a positive impact on the world
to build your team that's what you do in
CEO time and then you can get along with
the rest of your day and what you find
is oh at least I found if you don't
block that off and make it a priority
that CEO time and I think put it earlier
on in the day than later then you'll
find that the emergencies that happen to
you on a daily basis will just bleed
into your CEO time and you never
actually get time to focus on it and so
make it a priority block it off in your
calendar don't accept any meetings or
calls unless they're super ultra mega
huge emergencies so make sure you block
that off in your calendar CEO time
ideally 90 minutes every single day to
help you focus on the long term while
you're taking care of your short-term
priorities as well believe so the
question of the day today is I want to
know what you do to think about the long
term do you have CEO time what's in your
schedule right now the plan for what
you're doing longer term instead of
always being forced to focus on those
short-term issues leaving the comments
below
I'm curious to learn and I think it'll
also help the other people watching as
well thank you so much for watching have
an amazing day continue to believe and
I'll see you again tomorrow morning for
another shot of espresso
let's pray so give me go